hello everyone and welcome to a short
addition to the video I made yesterday
the first ever computer game uh that we
have recorded and it wasn't even played
on a computer Alan Turing um uh well
calculated the algorithm using pen and
paper and some of you asked a very
interesting question how come uh in the
first game that Alan Turing himself uh
using the algorithm played against his
colleague Alec Glenny uh the uh the sort
of algorithm opened with Ponto E4 uh but
then uh 60 years after after when the uh
when the program was actually ran on a
computer against Gary Kasparov in
Manchester in 2012 uh the computer
opened with P E3 which should not be
possible as it's the same algorithm and
I thought about this and I had no idea
why this is so so I asked on Twitter and
someone uh posted this article and uh
it's it's on chessbase.com you can read
it the entire thing I will put it in the
description below first thing you will
see will be the link uh but just give
you uh sort of the short version uh
let's uh get to how the how the
positions were calculated so touring and
Sher shown used the following peace
Values Pawn equals 1 Knight equals three
Bishop equals 3 and a half Rook equals 5
and queen equals 10 in addition they had
the following positional evaluation
functions so for the mobility as all of
the positions were awarded certain
points for the queen Rook bishop and
Knight added the square root of the
number of moves the piece can make count
each capture as two moves then for pie
safety for Rook bishop and Knight add
1.0 Point uh if it is defended and 1.5
points if it is defended at least twice
then you have the king Mobility for the
King the same as one except for castling
moves then for King safety for the king
deduct points for its vulnerability as
follows assumes that a queen of the same
color is on the king Square calculate
its mobility and then subtract the value
for from the score uh castling add 1.0
point for the possibility of still being
able to Castle on a later move if a king
or Rook move is being considered add
another point if castling can take place
on the next move finally add one more
point for actually castling Pawn credit
add 0.2 points for each rank Advanced
and 0.3 points for being defended by a
non pawn and mates and checks add 1.0
point for the threat of mate and 0 0.5
points for a check so that's how the
points were awarded and as it says at
the time there was no machine which we
discussed in the previous video so tring
had to conduct this uh experiment with
um pen and paper and okay here we have
uh the there's also a scan of ttings
faster than thought paper on Google Docs
also you can access it on the link in
the description below and in the
original submission typed by the author
on yellow paper with incorrection
touring quotes the game against Glenny
but deviates on move 20 1 from the game
score that was later published in all
the reprints uh it is to be assumed that
he corrected the first version of his
manuscript with the moves that have been
preserved for posterity as the game we
covered in the previous video so let's
go here and it says in the early 1950s
during began programming in Tamp on a
feny mark1 computer we've discussed that
in the previous video at the University
of Manchester at the same time he tried
implementing a rival program mavelli by
Donald Mishi and sha Wy on the same
machine fortunately he had not completed
the task before his tragic death in 1954
and now interestingly nobody seems to
have written an actual computer program
using turing's algorithm for more than
50 years after touring devised it in
2004 uh the programming team at chess
based software company decided to create
a chess engine based on touring's
algorithms uh the basis was touring's
description and the simple game against
the Glenny and the programmer who
undertook the task was Matias Feist he
built a standard chess program interface
face for the chess based Fritz program
so that the Turing engine could be
tested and in the process however the
chess based team encountered the program
the engine refused to duplicate all of
touring's moves recorded in the Glenny
game it deviated in 10 places
significantly already on the first move
uh the touring engine wanted to play 1
E3 whereas touring had executed 1 E4 in
his 1952 game does the confusion in the
video that I made what what made uh the
algorithm go e three against casparo in
2012 and against al Glen in 1952 the
algorithm wanted to play E4 well uh they
spent quite a lot of time on this
actually the chess based team spent some
weeks reexamining the touring papers and
discussing the implementation of the
touring engine since they could not
locate the era they consulted Ken
Thompson one of the pioneers of computer
chess and author of Unix and C he spent
some time wrestling with the problem and
in fact wrote his own code on the basis
of his reading of detering instructions
his program prod produced most of Chess
based deviations from the Glenny game
and it was quite baffling so Frederick
friedel contacted Donald mitchi who had
been uh with touring at Blatchley
describing the problem in general and
the most significant deviations the
chess base touring program uh produced
after the prescribed three ply search uh
which touring used on his paper and
pencil game it is possible that we have
got something wrong he wrote uh but I
doubt it since very often especially in
the beginning we get the same moves with
exactly the same value I think it is
possible that touring tired after uh 15
moves when in addition uh the position
became quite complex uh mish's reaction
in a phone conversation was you are
looking for a bug in the program
Frederick no no no you should look for
it uh in Alan Turing Allan did not care
about the details he was interested in
the general principle he also pointed us
to a quote by shown who had assisted
touring during the 1952 game in the
actual experiment I suspect that we were
a bit slab Dash about all all of this
and must have made a number of slips uh
since the arithmetic was extremely
tedious with pencil and paper and in
June 2012 fredel traveled to Manchester
to attend the Allen Turing centen uh
Centenary conference on the way uh he
spent June 23rd uh touring's 100th
birthday at blachley Park a visit he
will never forget in Manchester he
assisted Gary Kasparov in a
commemorative lecture on touring's chess
involvement the two spoke about the
Reconstruction of the paper machine and
Kasparov actually played game against it
you can watch the entire one hour
lecture by clicking on the link uh in
the description below also will be in
the link that I provide if you want to
check that out and in the lecture
Kasparov pointed um to a key moment in
the game it was the first time that a
machine played a game of chess after a
pretty average game they reached an
equal position and the Machine blundered
a queen that famous Queen captures on D6
that we discussed and then the Rook just
uh picks up the queen so very very
interesting stuff kaspar says blundering
the queen in one move this is not a
great accomplishment but still the game
was played and there were 29 moves not
just legitimate moves but you may call
them decent moves So High Praise coming
from um former world champion gar
Kasparov he confirms that he will play a
game against the reconstructed engine
and at the end of the lecture which of
course uh you've seen in the previous
video uh in the lecture fredel discussed
the deviations we were confronted with
and how they probably came about an
important point is that during working
with paper and pen clearly used his
intuition to come up with the moves and
without knowing uh if he used the Alpha
Beta pruning a technique that was
invented by Alan Newell and Herbert a
Simon half a decade later when machines
could actually execute code essentially
Turing did not bother to calculate every
single move in a position some he
thought were clearly inferior and it
seemed pointless to spend a lot of time
working out exactly how bad they were
which is the point of Alpha Beta so
something that um uh Mo modern engines
due to today uh they they will simply
disregard some of the moves uh in the
lecture we discussed the pro pro problem
of the very first move that during play
E4 the chess base engine and Thompson's
reconstruction came up with Pawn to E3
and here it is very nicely explained why
paon to E3 using turing's own algorithm
is superior to pawn to E4 so in the
initial position material is equal no
pieces are taken nothing has happened
yet there are 20 legal moves for white
each of the eight pawns can move up um
one or two squares and the two knights
have two moves each one wonders if
touring made 20 calculations each taking
a number of minutes before he executed
the move uh the first move uh one E4 uh
it is one of the two most common moves
that start a chess game the other one is
uh well Pawn to D4 and uh let us apply
turing's rules to the initial position
so the E Pawn gets 0.4 points for moving
two squares forward but just 0.2 points
for moving one step that's rule six Pawn
credit so depending on how far the pawn
has advanced you get 0.2 points extra so
E4 is better but then we apply rule four
king safety by placing a queen on the
Square E1 counting the number of squares
the queen can move to they are the
squares from which the king could be
attacked by a rook or a bishop and
taking the square roote to Define its
Mobility E3 gets a malice of one square
root of one square square E2 to which
the queen can move whereas E4 reduced
the positional Advantage by 1.4 points
square root of two for E2 and E3 in his
game uh score Turing gives 4.2 points uh
for the move he played 1 E4 and adds an
asteris to the value which indicates
that every other move has a lower
positional uh play value the chess base
engine and that of um Ken Thompson gives
e E2 to E3 a positional value of 4.4 so
touring's move uh one E4 gets 4.2 points
whereas E3 gets 4.4 points but it seems
that during just disregarded the move
thinking obviously he he was a chess
player and he knew how to play chess uh
he just I guess assumed E4 was Superior
to E3 and it probably and I mean it is
uh only his algorithm as as crude as it
was thought uh E3 was better so uh
comparing to turing's move uh 0.2 less
for advancing just one Pawn but 0.4 more
for King safety Maas Feist wrote during
calculations for E2 E4 is correct which
means he did not really calculate one uh
1 E3 as a chess player he knew that this
move is not logical because in the
initial position King safety doesn't
play a role he play he probably looked
at it and thought everything is the same
for both moves except the E2 E3 uh is
0.2 points worse because the pawn moves
just one square whereas if the pawn
moves two squares it gets uh well 0
point .2 * 2 that's 0.4 so he
disregarded it without further
calculation uh incidentally the move 1
D2 to D4 uh one of the most popular in
tournament chest was certainly
calculated by touring who must have seen
that it is clearly worse putting a queen
on the king Square shows four squares to
which it can move uh the malice for King
safety is 2.0 so let's take a look at
move four touring played Knight G1 to F3
and gave the value of 2.0 the chess
based Turing engine play Play De
captures on E5 and gives it a value of
1.1 which is the correct move as I've
analyzed it thoroughly in the previous
video uh but yeah okay if you guys are
interested in the rest of the article
you can click on the first link in the
description below and you can check it
out uh but the point is um uh the the
problem why E3 uh was played in the game
against casparo in 2012 and the E4 uh
was played uh against Alex Glen in
1952 uh seems that it's uh specific
specifically because Alan Turing knew
how to play chess so he you know from
from the two moves E3 and E4 he probably
thought okay I'm not going to waste even
more time calculating this because we
all know E4 is superior and it is unless
you know next year a really strong
engine comes along and says no no E3 is
far superior and it all you know uh I
remember some 15 years ago maybe 20
years ago I was in a bar and I was
discussing chess with a with a colleague
of mine back then and he was a casual
player never really had any training and
he was convinced and no one could
convince him otherwise that uh the best
position you could have is the starting
position and then uh whoever makes the
first move and white always makes the
first move that the white is first the
first one to introduce sort of Chaos in
the balance and uh you have to ruin your
position so the starting position is the
perfect one and then whoever makes the
first move ruins that Perfection and
then the other player gets chance to
also ruin the Perfection his own way and
then you know back and forth so it's a
merely a way of uh preserving the
Perfection as long as you can and if
your opponent uh you know ruins it a bit
too much you will get winning chances
and you are able to win the game which
sort of contradicts what we know that
white has the advantage of the first
move and it's always better to be white
uh you know he always thought that it is
white who who gets a chance first at at
ruining the the Perfection of the of the
starting position uh but yeah just
wanted to get that in as a lot of you
have been asking this question how how
is it possible that the exact same
algorithm that should produce the exact
same move I produced a different move UH
60 years ago and then you guys said that
okay maybe the chess based team didn't
really uh make a good copy of the of the
touring of Touro champ touring's
algorithm but no they did a very good
job uh it seems that touring just uh
himself disregarded E2 E3 as the as the
best move according to his own algorithm
uh so yeah uh you've been informed hope
hope this helps and that your uh
question has been answered if you have
any other uh questions regarding the
matter I'm uh more than happy to look
into it as I was uh also you know when I
first read your questions I was like
yeah uh first of all I've never really
thought of it uh and uh second of all
yeah it is Def it definitely is weird
because I thought okay uh nowadays the
the engine will maybe give you different
recommendations but it will Al okay will
say E4 Knight F3 C4 D4 and they are all
you know fine moves but it will always
rank that uh one move at maybe 0.5
Advantage wide then it will maybe rank
the second one at 0.4 then 0.3 but one
will always be the highest ranked and of
course then the next year there will be
a stronger engine and a stronger engine
and a stronger engine and the evaluation
might um you know uh change but uh yeah
uh all in all hope this answers your
question uh so yeah that's the not
that's the game because there was no
game if you want to check out the game
and if you haven't seen that video do
check it out will be also in the
description first link will be link to
this article and second link will be to
the actual games between Alec Glenny and
alen Turing and then uh between to
Champion Gary kaspar so do check that
out I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Caroline a and I would like
to thank Anna panov Robert kefir Welsh
fan frankpl for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous this video is here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
uh and whatever else happens in the
Chess World uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day